(audience laughing)
- [Ross] Hey Gunther, you
got stairs in your place.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, go nuts.
(audience laughs)
- Rachel?
- Yeah.
- I know you're leaving tonight,
but I just have to tell you.
I love you.
(audience laughs)
- Mike hit my mom with a car.
- No, I didn't.
Seriously, you wanna make one of those?
- One, how about a whole bunch?
- Really?
- Yeah.
Oh we can teach them to sing
and we can be like the von Trapp family.
(audience laughs)
- Hey Janice.
- Oh my God, I am so glad you called me.
I had the most supremely awful day.
- Oh my--
- Yeah yeah yeah.
(audience laughs)
I must have you Janice
Litman-Goralnik, nee Hosenstein.
(audience laughs)
- Chandler, what are you talking about?
- Martha Ludwin's daughter
is gonna call you.
Mmm, what's that curry taste?
Curry.
(audience laughs)
Mmm.
- I think they're great, I really do.
- Do you remember the Ludwins?
The big one had a thing
for you, didn't she?
- They all had a thing for him.
- We better get going, it's late.
Jack's not allowed to
drive at night anymore,
he has trouble staying in his lane.
- The last winter I went
up on a church's lawn
and drove right through a manger scene.
The papers thought it was a hate crime.
(audience laughs)
- Anyway, it was lovely seeing you.
- Oh there's the waitress.
Excuse me, miss.
Hello, miss?
- It's Phoebe.
Hi.
- Hey.
- Hi.
Okay, will that be all?
(audience laughs)
We really better get going.
- Oh right, you have a
church group meeting tonight.
- Right.
(audience laughs)
- Hello.
- [Emily] Hello.
(Monica screeches)
(audience laughs)
(Rachel shrieks in excitement)
- Emily?
- Yes.
- I'm Rachel Green.
- Thank goodness.
- Yeah.
There has been tiny, tiny change of plans.
Turns out I'm not free tonight, so--
- Really?
(chuckles) Well, that's
just lovely, isn't it?
I must have missed your call,
even though I didn't
leave the flat all day.
Are you thinking about me?
No, of course you're not.
But if you are, call me tonight.
Okay, bye.
(answering machine beeps)
- No!
(audience laughs)
- Oh hey hey, I got that.
- Oh, thanks sweetie.
- No problem.
♪ All my life ♪
- I cannot wait for
you to meet my friends.
- Really?
- Yeah.
- You don't think they'll
judge and ridicule me?
- No no, they will, I just...
- Can't wait.
- Can't wait. (laughs)
Come on, they're gonna love you.
- Hey.
- Hey Julie.
- Julie.
Hey, how are you doing?
- Oh, oh I don't know.
I mean, it's definitely
weird not being with Ross,
but I guess I'm doing okay.
Actually, I've got some
of his stuff that he...
(orchestral music)
(audience laughs)
- It's James Bond.
- Sorry we're late.
- That's okay, come on in.
I'm sorry, is Monica Geller coming?
I was told she was.
- Dr. Burke, it's me.
- Monica?
If you do get her,
don't let her go.
Trust me.
- You know, Richard, you are a good guy.
(audience laughs)
- I know.
I hate that.
(audience laughs)
(door opens)
(door slams)
- Guys, there is somebody
I'd like you to meet.
(monkey mumbling)
- [Friends] Aw!
- Wait, wait, what is that?
- That would be Marcel.
You wanna say hi?
- No, no, I don't.
- You know, he's moved on.
Hey, that's the way it goes, right?
(Marcel tapping)
- Oh my God.
- What?
(upbeat music)
- No, no no no, I'm not
saying you're not talented.
You're very talented.
It's just that with the bird dead and all,
there's very little act left.
(audience laughs)
Joey, it's Estelle.
- Hey.
- [Estelle] So, how did
your audition go today.
- What audition?
- The one I told you about last week.
- What, you need said
anything about an audition.
(audience laughs)
- Let me start over.
I just got a call about an audition.
(audience laughs)
I think you can still make it.
It's down at the Esther Theater
and you need to have a monologue prepared.
- Kitty kitty kitty.
Come here, kitty kitty
kitty kitty kitty kitty,
kitty,
kitty...
Hi.
- Buona sera.
- Wow.
- Buongiorno a tutti.
(audience laughs)
- Ew!
- Oh.
- Ross!
- Hey ho.
Ah ha.
What a.
(audience laughs)
What are you doing here?
- I do Raquel.
- Ah.
(audience laughs)
(Bobby knocking)
- Everybody, it's Fun Bobby!
- [Everybody] Fun Bobby!
- Hey Bobby!
- Hey, sorry I'm late,
but my grandfather died
about two hours ago.
But I couldn't get a flight
out 'til tomorrow, so,
here I am.
- [Monica] Hi, I'll be
ready in just a second.
- Can I talk to you a minute?
- [Monica] Sure.
- Look, I am just not strong enough
to be in a codependent
relationship right now, okay?
- Oh shoot.
(audience laughs)
- Well, anyway, I hope we can be friends.
- Okay.
(lips smack)
Take care.
- Okay, you too.
- Bye.
There's nothing to tell, it's
just some guy I work with.
- Come on.
You're going out with the guy,
there's gotta be something wrong with him.
(audience laughs)
- So, does he have a hump,
a hump and a hairpiece?
(audience laughs)
- Wait, does he eat chalk?
Just 'cause I don't want her to go through
what I went through with Carl, ah.
(audience laughs)
- Okay, everybody relax.
This is not even a date.
It's just two people going out to dinner
and not having sex.
- Sounds like a date to me.
(audience laughs)
(gentle music)
- Hi.
(audience laughs)
- This guy says hello,
I wanna kill myself.
(audience laughs)
- Are you okay, sweetie?
- I just feel like someone
reached down my throat,
grabbed my small intestine,
pulled it out of my mouth,
and tide it around my neck.
- Cookie?
(audience laughs)
- Carol moved her stuff out today.
- [Everybody] Oh.
- Let me get you some coffee.
- Thanks.
- Ohh, oh.
- No, no, don't, stop cleansing my aura.
(audience laughs)
- Come on, you're single,
have some hormone.
- See, but I don't want
to be single, okay?
I just wanna be married again.
(audience laughs)
- And I just want a million dollars.
- Rachel?
- Oh God, Monica, hi, thank God.
I just went to your building
and you weren't there
and then this guy with a big hammer
said that you might be
here, and you are, you are.
- Can I get you some coffee?
- Decaf.
(audience laughs)
Okay, everybody, this is Rachel,
another Lincoln High survivor.
This is everybody.
This is Chandler, and Phoebe, and Joey.
And you remember my brother Ross?
- Sure.
- Hey.
- Hi.
Oh!
(audience laughs)
- Wow.
- I know.
It seems smaller somehow.
- Has it always been purple?
(audience laughs)
- Look around, you guys.
This was your first home.
And it was a happy place.
Filled with love and laughter.
But more important,
because of rent control,
it was a freaking steal.
(audience laughs)
- Hey, do you realize that
at one time or another,
we all lived in this apartment?
- [Rachel] Oh yeah, that's true.
- Oh, I haven't.
(audience laughs)
- What about that summer during college
that you lived with grandma
and you tried to make it as a dancer?
(audience laughs)
- Do you realize we
almost made it 10 years
without that coming up?
(audience laughs)
- Oh honey, I forgot.
I promised Treeger that
we'd leave our keys.
- Oh okay.
(boots stomping softly)
(keys thud)
(audience laughs)
(keys clinking)
(Joey sighs)
- So I guess this is it.
- Yeah.
I guess so.
- This is harder than
I thought it would be.
- Oh it's gonna be okay.
Come on.
(everybody sniffling)
- Do you guys have to go
to the new house right away
or do you have some time? (sniffles)
- We have some time.
- Okay, should we get some coffee?
- Sure.
Where?
(audience laughs)
(gentle music)